I would like to talk about the state of
Enchantment known as deep play deep play
is a dance a love affair with the sacred
it thrusts us into a liminal space a
kind of threshold space between this
world and the next
deep play is the world of make-believe
it's the world of mythologies the world
of storytelling and legend deep play is
a place to unleash the imagination to
free ourselves from the mundane to
transcend the ordinary and Riaan chant
the world a state of play is a state of
animism where the world comes alive
where the architecture mediates your
experience where the song takes you on a
magic carpet ride it is the space in
which we can play pretend it is the
world in which we can create our own
cosmos we look upon children with envy
for their capacity to live essentially
in the Garden of Eden they live in a
state of play they're wrapped inside
their own imaginations and as adults
without growth as we grow stiff and we
grow bored we grow fearful and we grow
stable we crave these kinds of
experiences that awakened the mais
attention from the lethargy of custom in
the film of familiarity and redirected
instead towards the wonders of existence
we want we longed to see the world in a
grain of
and in heaven in a wild flower we all
want to hold infinity in the palms of
our hands
and eternity in an hour we look to our
poets our noble savages to remind us in
language of what is possible to remind
us that there is no limit to the human
spirit right we look upon such phrases
as those who were seeing dancing were
called insane by those who could not
hear the music we fill the classrooms of
our children's with lines such as the
only people for me are the mad ones mad
to live mad to talk mad to be saved
desirous of everything at the same time
those who never yawn are saying a
commonplace thing but burned burned
burned like yellow roman candles
exploding like spiders across the stars
we celebrate the Raps city in the
anguish and the poetry of lions like
these of quotes like these we make
bumper stickers and we hang them on our
fridge to remind us of the life of
authenticity that we long to live and
yet at the same time who everywhere
around us we see the opposite the
signalling and the messaging is to
conform to grow out of childish dreams
to settle
to deaden this is the faint it's quiet
this is the worm at the core will want
cosmological ah and wonder we all want
cosmic heroism we want to slay the
Dragons we want to face our fears we
want to surrender and submit because if
you cannot submit you cannot die and if
you cannot die you cannot be reborn we
want apotheosis we want rebirth we want
transformation
and we're so scared and we're so
sad
[Music]
but I refuse to relinquish that flame we
won't go quietly into that good night
will rage against the dying of the lies
with our artistry in our imagination
with new toolkits for the mind with new
technologies of ecstasy with our new
capacity to mediate the contents of our
consciousness and reclaim stewardship of
internal life we will become the masters
of our fate and become the captains of
our soul this is not a sad story at the
end of the day this is just this is a
fork in the road all of our existential
dread is collectively a global fork in
the road for our species where will we
go but towards mediocrity and
self-destruction annihilation and or
towards the reverence towards the
rapturous will we heed the call will we
answer the calling will we climb to the
summit of the mountain in a war I hope
so